- I can't even watch!
- Look at it, there's like
this big wrinkle in her lip.
- It's horrible!
(romantic violin music)
I think this is gonna be awkward.
- It's kind of a lot of pressure.
- I think this is gonna feel so right.
- Nothing's weird to me.
- We know what to do.
- [Voiceover] On your marks!
- Ready, ready for this, let's go.
(slow piano music)
(laughter)
- Oh my god, I look like a doper!
I look like a doper!
- That is really weird looking!
- Oh, I don't like it! (laughs)
I don't wanna watch it!
- It's not like I've really
seen us kiss before, anyway?
- Her beanie is, she looks like a smurf.
- I look like a smurf.
- I did get a big chunk of your under gum.
- Oh, that's gross.
- Cause I'm gonna bite her lip off.
She's not having it.
- Cool, I had like five chins.
- Looks like I'm giving
you CPR, or something.
- It does!
- Now, now I look good.
Yeah, that's just right.
- This is good, this is good.
- It's not as grotesque,
cause my hair is kind of
like, blowing in the wind.
- And you've got your hand on my face.
- See, that's cute.
- See, I told you.
- I think it does look like a movie.
- I see some chemistry there.
(laughs)
- It's so nice when it's just like...
- Yeah, this is like...
- Slow-mo kissing is beautiful.
- Aww, we look adorable.
- Thank you for that.
- You're welcome.
- Wow, I really have no chin, either.
It's just like a giant slope.
That's so sweet, you would kiss that.